Tom Hanks must really like movies where
he saves people saving mr. banks stars
Emma Thompson and Tom Hanks in this
movie is the based on the true story
tale of the author of Mary Poppins being
very reluctant to sell the film rights
to Walt Disney played by tom hanks emma
thompson plays P L Travers the author of
the original Mary Poppins and this story
is extremely dear to her and this films
about why that story is so dear to her
why it relates to her past you see Colin
Farrell as her father when she was a
youth and he get the past story of her
youth along with the present and you get
to see how those two stories meshed
together I heard a lot of good things
about this movie going into it and
that's to be expected with talent like
Emma Thompson and Tom Hanks involved
with it these are two really good actors
and they both shine in this movie
especially Emma Thompson I don't know
anything about the author Mary Poppins
all I know is that she was great in the
movie and she plays this character who's
at first you're like wow this is an
extremely uppity annoying woman like the
biggest like just ice queen you don't
want to be around this girl ever she has
a problem with virtually everything that
anyone does she's got like no friends
Paul Giamatti plays her driver and
through him you can kind of start to see
maybe a shred of humanity in this woman
but it's really in the backstory we
watch her as a youth growing up with
Colin Farrell as her father well you
really get to understand why that story
is so dear to her heart Tom Hanks plays
Walt Disney as I said and I wonder if he
was good in the movie oh yeah he's Tom
Hanks he was really good in the movie
there are moments when the movie gets a
little overly sentimental and kind of
melodramatic it kind of hits you with
all those cliched Disney punches of
certain things happening where you're
supposed to feel really bad but there
was one legitimate moment in this movie
that really did touch me and for that
reason I obviously was hooked to the
emotional part of this story even though
some of it did get a little cheesy Colin
Farrell was also very good as her
childhood father I like him a lot as an
actor and he added a very important
element to this movie that really helped
a lot of the emotion pay off but really
the most entertaining part of this movie
for me was watching Emma Thompson and
Walt Disney tried to make this movie
together and try to figure out how they
could make this film because I've always
loved filmmaking from when I was a
teenager and I used to do that with my
friends all the time we'd sit down we'd
draw storyboards we'd write out scripts
we'd think about music we could make and
we
did that kind of stuff as a kid so it
was really entertaining trying to watch
these characters figure out how to make
the film and that was my favorite aspect
of this movie so whenever it went back
to the past I wasn't quite as invested
in that element of it but I still
understand why it's there and it
definitely added a lot of emotion to the
film Emma Thompson is terrific in this
movie she definitely shines in this role
she's the kind of character where at
first she seemed a certain way but you
can really tell there's a lot of stuff
behind her as Christopher Walken said in
Seven Psychopaths
it's got Leia's I did feel the movie was
just a tad bit too long though maybe by
like 10 or 15 minutes but there's
definitely a lot of touching scenes in
this movie and the central story was
very interesting and makes you look at
Mary Poppins in a different way as well
some people have look at this movie and
said it was just kind of a lot of
propaganda to make people love Disney a
lot and I can see why they would say
that but I still think that it was such
a well acted movie and it was made with
a lot of care so I'm gonna give saving
mr. banks a B+ guys thanks very much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my next
[Music]